okay for those joining this livestream
we are trying to finalize aspects of
chemical computation for the upcoming
version of off language so we are
starting off with where should we start
should we start um let's see so I was
looking at it and I was thinking it who
has gone through this as as Michael gone
through these or not having gone through
this we went to a couple of individual s
pages yes okay so you haven't gone
through this particular one I haven't
gone through the guide page no okay but
but so what would you like me to go
through so if you look above I was when
I was reading this I was looking at that
table and I found the table the table
followed by error following an atom's
can be specified in the following forms
I found it to be slightly confusing the
the uppercase s y and so my thought was
that the sentence the second sentence in
the notes and usage could take the place
of the table so atoms can be entered as
atomic symbols atom objects or as either
an elementary so up entity no okay I
mean we can say we can do something like
this where we have again I don't know
whether you got this straightened out
who is here for who is doing project
management stuff here okay but typically
we don't give tables for arguments when
the argument
so diverse like this I think we can and
do I think it will be clear for clearer
for people if we do this look it'll be
most people will just look at the
examples anyway I'm looking for the
special text arts because it's in the
wrong place here um
[Music]
okay so are you confused because of the
capital letter
so I showed that to a couple of people
and they said what is Sai didn't or
something
yeah why not that's why I'm I think this
is reasonable and as of right now when
you to template in my by the way this
isn't this isn't you can specify country
just give an integer there for an atom
you can it's preferred way to do an
entity element data it takes an integer
an entity value entity takes the integer
fur for courtesy I believe but I also
would be a little bit reluctant to
document this because we sort of need
the atom indices people might actually
get confused okay let's see and one
thing when you format an entity like
that entity isotope the isotope becomes
a link to the interpreter page Ellen on
the compose okay should go to it should
link yes yes yep okay all right now be
be done the post-processing on the
documentation okay represents so there
was the point was that no those two
forms are fine
okay okay you don't have to say this you
don't have to make a marketing point
about this I mean it always converts
always evaluates to perform that
I mean technically only when it can like
molecular uh end of junk okay well then
you should say that evaluates as
possible um so I think and then the
second one can go when you want your
table yes okay should we talk about
valence you know covalent bonding and
all that kind of stuff
no so the molecule page hopefully you
know you know listen listen okay
hopefully Michael will fix these things
but but or return true from molecule Q
that's not not the right molecule q will
give true on valid molecules molecule Q
of mall will give true when I don't know
what I was saying that on a molecule
page I think it's important because like
if you have something that's had
molecule occur and you wanted it is a
sensitive one locus gives true only if
mall corresponds to a valid molecule
so that last form their molecule of mole
you're not giving that in there in the
in the thing at the top which is also
wrong I think okay what I'm saying so
the that form I don't understand this
because you've got molecule or atom
comma bond
you've got molecule of a molecule only
with indices ID from molecule so that's
a different form of molecule than this
yes it's it's like the it's performing
the action of subgraph in this case we
should take type here so women so we've
got a different form here which is
molecule of molecule comma blah blah
blah right yeah which is a different
form that's this case here and then I'm
gonna switch here in a moment to look in
some other things okay so what does that
give
okay why on earth will be not reference
chemical chemical data here because I
wasn't I was not being conclusive ah
yeah so it's not right
yeah okay and co-authors are not yet
done
okay all right fine okay what will be
most useful for me to do shall I try and
clean up the guide page so I have a
couple of open questions I don't he'll
fine so let's good let's good go to the
open questions sorry I shouldn't have
gone in this detail no no I so it's good
weed there's a couple of open questions
on molecule value and then I think we
should look at molecule plot atom list
bond list whose these okay what okay
that's certainly not the second thing
there no it's not Bob and I were talking
that there should be a perhaps sections
here to separate these things and so
that would go under molecule mod so so
there's a whole section on the graph
guide page about graph modifications
since we would do something some well no
look look let's
okay so first we have molecule
representation okay so then we've got
atom and bond probably okay now I
probably want the testing functions um
oh actually we need the include
hydrogen's somewhere don't we so the
actual options for molecule
stereochemistry elements okay
the representation
[Music]
okay so here we would have
include hydrogen's now what's that for
that is not only for output or is that
for input also
do you understand my question
rate so focus presentation
it's a constructor option you give it
and what you get back doesn't have that
option in it anymore okay okay so what
should this say whether to include
whether to treat whether to implicitly
add hydrogen atoms for unsatisfied bonds
or something I might say unfilled
valence --is
okay okay so then we've got um
stereochemistry elements and Adam
coordinates right yes
so Adam coordinates would be specified
explicitly specify coordinates of atoms
in a molecule that correct right answer
there I would specify that it's
three-dimensional coordinates the 2d
coordinates diagram or zip it okay all
right okay so now stereochemistry
elements right so we've rewrote the
usage message for that just last night
so it's the fairly decent or okay
okay do we want to say anything about
no okay all right that's those things so
now we have um the things that test
structure basically
so be molecule equal molecule q well
first things like bond or what about
bonds and atom list and so on molecular
structure so that ends up being I would
think this thing's like atom list that
they're right probably as well as fine
molecule substructure unless we want to
have a separate section for patterns and
such we do um okay so then we've got
bond QM molecule Q test for a valid
molecule and I think we want bond cube
its bond Q our only other one of these
yes and unless so if we don't count
molecule equal in this group I don't
think we should um
you
I'll give it to what about connected
molecule Q and things so those are okay
um okay so next we have visualization
for which we have molecule plot or
molecule plot 3d right yes okay what can
we say about this we can't hear you
beyond you don't have molecule graph
anymore that's right here right so
that's the the graph related functions
right
there's also visualization what no it's
not okay it's for computation
okay so this is going to be okay so what
should we say about molecule plot so
produces a two dimensional structure
diagram of the molecule 2d molecular
structure diagram so how is that
optimized can we say something about how
its optimized or how its created I mean
is it is it like is there an unique one
of these I'm not sure I understand
no most chemists don't every unique one
how does it decide which one to do so so
where to place the atoms and whatnot
like what diet how to make the day let's
I mean so it's it uses something like
the the spring embedding except knowing
that we have preferred bond angles
things like with allowing automatic
layout with automatic layout allowing
automatic layout
okay so 3d what should we say here 3d
static it's awesome
so there's a model you want to say
something about it's a model Bob okay
what is Bob there Bob
you might be sorry I thought I had just
a muted myself yes I'm here okay so what
3d molecular structure 3d molecular
representation or what what should we
say 3d molecular representation based on
a model based on yeah based on a model
I'm just trying to think of the right
model to the right words for that which
generally is the distance this show this
shouldn't be this way that should be
include hydrogen's right that's not a
string option please don't use a string
option there aren't there shouldn't be
string options right okay right right
now so we it originally would have been
thinking that show hydrogen's was a
separate thing from include hydrogen's
but now there's no reason that molecule
pod can't take and include hydrogen's to
mean show hydrogen's okay so you'll deal
with this yep okay all right okay so go
ahead so molecular structure
visualization your three month a
structure visualization or 3d molecular
rendering of 3d molecular rendering
based on energy minimization model or
something distance geometry I think is
probably what we want to say at this
point cuz that's it on a chemical model
based on a chemical model is best yes
right because molecule plant 3d doesn't
have to compute the coordinates if you
don't keep it a molecule that has them
already that you brought in from some
file it's not going to yeah so will be
based on well so so I'm saying with
automatic layout here so we can say with
Matic physics computation or something
so automatically generated
yes automatically generated 3d
coordinates 3d atom coordinates if
necessary I was saying with so it's like
a optional feature so on the livestream
people are asking what I want to search
for molecules that will bind to certain
sites on a given enzyme can this be
computed well not directly right
I mean you can do that by by knowing a
particular structure that you want to
find a particular medical structure that
you want to find right right and so
people then would often start with a big
enzyme and look for molecules that have
the right shape and that's a direction
we could move in the future but then
yeah can again go bind as a molecule
synthesizable is radioactivity model but
we have isotopes at least we have all
kinds of stuff but no the answer is no
they're not yet maybe we can use our
automated theorem proving technology to
be able to figure out synthesis pathways
that would be a lot of fun and not get
wheatley crazy the god-good technology
for that ok so now here
generate a graph generate the graph get
get the graph get a graph representation
of the bonds and a molecule that right
do we want to somehow mention that we're
annotating the graph with all the
properties the the vertices and edges
get an annotated graph
of the bonds and a molecule bonds and
atoms or atoms and bonds
okay so now we got connected compartment
logical components connected molecule
cue
test whether a molecule object
represents a single connected molecule
this seems a little bit circular okay
well what should it say I feel active or
connected to the rest of us or to bonds
okay test whether a molecule is
connected with bought via bonds or
something represents a single covalently
bound
yeah something various as for a single
covalently bound strong structure okay
okay all right next connected molecule
components give a list of independent
covalently bound structures is that
right yes that would be right okay
all right we've done those we've done
those we've done those done those we've
done those okay so do we do molecule
value next what does molecule value all
I want to compute here so a wide variety
of computed properties can i compute the
boiling point
it's
the property of a molecule it's true
we've been through that before okay
yeah so it also returns inherent
properties you know something like the
atom list okay but but does it compute
things that are require physical
computation or does it merely compute
structural properties of molecules no it
does like the distance matrix is another
things and it's not unreasonable that we
would in the future have a computed
boiling point property there are a
couple of models that allow you to
compute the boiling point from a
structure you know but we can get
something like molecular volume or
surface area right now so those would be
I think what one would consider a real
computed property okay exit Sciences
like diamino something yeah and the MMFF
energy for example that's also
computable okay okay so here we've got
find
sheral or computed properties of
molecules right yeah okay
all right so now um the next step here
is this molecule matching an N molecule
modificator kill property
it's like entity property it so it
represents an operator form and you can
lump together the any qualifiers into
the property okay so find structural in
structural find values of structural
computed properties of molecules okay so
then the next thing is molecule property
which is symbolic representation of the
molecular property it's that right yes
okay so next we have probably molecule
equal what does that do so it tests for
equivalence of molecules it's equivalent
the
we'll know so I mean so it has
comparison is a better word here because
it does have their old string valued
same tests alright
test for molecular or compare test for
molecular equivalence with various
criteria so it's a function that I
considered naming molecule isomer Q but
I think equal just sounds sounds e
sounds better
well is it right I mean is that right
the right thing because is it you know
that sounds like it's very mathematical
I mean equal would um we decided that is
we had at one point thought molecule
same but equal and equal versus same in
the language implies computation equal
can do computation and so that's why we
we liked it better than molecule same
and same implies byte wise equality
which were no no I I would think it
should be molecule equivalent on
molecule equivalence I think molecule
equal is really weird and so it couldn't
be equivalent q cuz it is guaranteed to
return true or false then that's what it
should be cold that's what it should be
cold yeah yeah it's change it
okay um what we call this molecular
property computation our molecular
structure computation I know what that
really means and it's really a graph
those are good things
yeah but I think I know what this under
it seems to represent it but when its
own one portly has a different idea of
what molecule lost or computation means
okay fine I think nobody needs you okay
so hold on so let's say I like Hill a
graph computation how about that so you
don't like the word comparison in this
case but it's not just comparison we're
gonna put all the properties down here
the next thing we have to have is this
fine like a substructure Oracle contains
Q and so on well let's let's put it down
molecule contains Q next
test whether a molecule contains a
specified structure as that right yes
this should say something is this graph
based molecular computation
I mean this is basically all but not all
okay I mean structure computation right
that's what I wrote before in its own
you think when something is yeah
Michael's right I think we're stuff to
do with 3d geometry and so on right okay
so there's fine molecular substructure
what what do we say about that see so
what did so if you look at the usage
message for that I talked about a
mapping it returns a mapping between a
substructure
yeah Ronnie's asking for her um
abundance of molecules on earth and
space you know guys you're asking for a
lot
we've got elemental abundances we've had
that for a long time generated x-ray
crystallography patterns of molecules
really tough um well actually in the
sense we have that and a sense we have
we have the 3d structure so but we don't
have how it crystallizes we have the 3d
structure so that's what you need
foremost for like protein
crystallography and things right and the
Cambridge crystallographic database has
what hundred thousand chemical
structures crystallographic structures
if the user has those data the crystal
could be built from that with you the
molecules in the unit cell all arranged
properly and stuff I've done that in the
past still for the future here yeah for
the future for the future I'm afraid the
aroma of a molecule also for the future
I'm afraid we have we're representing
many kinds of things we've got some but
we're not we're not there yet on
representing them um yeah by the way how
are we specifying shouldn't we list in
this guide page various kinds of things
like edge form and style and so on our
killer visualization shouldn't we list
here
whatever these things are outside they
should specify a system it's a distinct
plot or ball and stick claw how do we
specify two different versions we have I
don't know you tell me okay it seems
what's that
they're basically plot seems right more
so in this spot style is important you
can wrapper right right right and pod
themes I don't fully have ready
I imagine some really cool plot themes
for these okay so that's for the future
so all the four
the ball and stick oh oh oh if we live
you plaid 3d I do have um okay so hold
on we've got style we've got edge form
what other kinds of things do you use
right so I use stadium shape to make all
of those those even means what you can
use at the top level not what you use
internally so in other words you've got
and you've gotta say that in the
documentation that you can put style
around bonds and so on so I'm saying
right yeah so right so the color
directories to route and annotations
actually we should say here and note a
table 2d a note a table 2d structure
diagram makes sense yeah and the 3d is
also is likewise an attainable line I'm
gonna leave that out because I think
it's less important I think we should
say would user supplied or automatically
generated coordinates sorry we only get
one line here okay I just don't want it
to imply that it's only automatically
generated layout
yeah okay that's good okay so
so what kinds of annotations are allowed
and by the way things like maximum
common substructure presumably I don't
even know what that what is that so
that's something I'm gonna push for in
the next release it was okay so that's
not ready yet right okay all right fun
so is style the main thing to use here
or what does slide look style in a
pattern and then any directives I have
not made call out work yet you should I
don't think we can okay
because because of the interaction of
the lines like classify styles um color
etc styles for highlighted sub
structures for just some structures
molecular substructures highlighting for
molecular
substructures right okay so which which
things work edge form works what else
works so face form would work color
directives opacity else that's all it
comes to mind at the moment
I mean they're obviously other weird
ones that work but Tim okay so now do we
want to mention any graph theory
functions in Mike allografts and by the
way don't forget that we need to put
these on graph guide pages okay so what
what would be the most commonly used
graph theoretic functions here so find
cycles find path find hamiltonian path
okay hold on hold on hold on and that
might want to point to a graph theory
page I mean now they're also all these
indices graph indices which are relevant
to this so there's index graph right
what does that mean I don't think
they're relevant okay what were you
referring to things like the kir Hall
connectivity disease those we have under
the properties right Jason yes under
molecular value look yeah
there's a whole plethora of those that
are computable okay
okay um okay going down here I like a
comparison okay so now we have all this
fine molecule substructure can you
describe what that does so so it finds
so obviously it finds the substructure
in a molecule and returns a an
association mapping the indices from the
molecule to the substructure but
obviously it needs to be shorter than
that find a substructure find a location
of a substructure in a molecule find
where a substructure occurs in a
molecule
and now molecular pattern molecule
pattern that's symbolic
presentation your molecular substructure
right yes okay so now we have modifying
molecules and there we have molecule
modify modify faithful molecule pit down
it's a substructure not structure so I I
mean I like I like the sub because it
implies that it can be automatically
thing radical finger thing or something
right it can it can be a single aromatic
bond which would not make a valid
molecule actually why don't we say
symbolic pattern representing or
something symbolic pattern representing
molecule a sub structure yeah he'll also
be sub structure in a molecule contains
Q
is that right
specified substructure no I I don't
think so or should it be sub structure
there I think yeah I don't I don't have
an opinion I mean it does look for a sub
structure but it could also you could
give a contest for the presence of
itself right yes and if you have
something like a cluster of molecules
for example from a gas phase experiment
you want to know if that cluster
contains a specific whole molecule which
is not the whole cluster so it would
support that okay import and export
molecular structures right yes and so I
haven't edited those pages yet okay
chemical properties that's where we have
to talk about either the entity page or
chemical data extensive
properties of chemicals of named
chemicals of knowin chemicals on known
chemicals reasonable yeah yeah okay
that's that page alright let's look at
what what else we need to look at here
so the ones that I let me just tell you
ya know string options okay no string
options okay so can I have that as a
symbol or what no no you cannot we need
to talk about it okay um yeah so what
symbol would I use for that up I don't
know I don't know how many more things
like that are there that are kind of
hanging out there other way here what
the hell is this
what's that thing show aromatic bonds we
discussed this yesterday we know they
take you away they have to go away well
how how are we going to deal with this I
mean are we going you see the first row
should be trust make their method
sub-options well but don't I mean or we
could have them as symbols I'm not sure
if it no first time to deeply think
about all of them right now how many are
there I do not I'm not sure I can I will
remove every string option it seems to
me that should be a more general option
and then you can have string settings
for I think so like you know if one had
something like you know molecular
display options or something you can
have a whole giant list of these things
if there is a giant list I don't know if
there's a giant list then Meyer is a
giant list that I have wrapped up in
okay well fine so fine so then it should
be just molecular display options okay
so so I'll make a but I'll put this in
as a as a future eyes thing and that
would then end up being some kind of
association of just all kinds of kitchen
sinks all right now Oh
this oh that's the same that's right
inside the names right inside okay I
think okay well great let's molecule
equal molecule equivalent q it seems to
me it might as well just take three
arguments so it can be varargs or it can
take a whole list of molecules but that
shouldn't be a problem if I just test at
the last no no no no no no if we're
really gonna do that um so I model
there's a nice president fine graphics a
partisan takes multiple graphs okay all
right fine fine fine fine okay all right
that sounds okay okay interesting
yeah okay looks good all right
don't we don't
rapper okay that needs to get fixed
somehow
um hey a point for Alex if alex is with
us well just a minute hold on a second
let's see to a comment on the twitch
chat we're very interested in being able
to plot electron densities so in the
next version will be importing these
cube files from Gaussian which contain
electron densities and electron wave
functions what happened to our own
efforts to think about using machine
learning to generate basis functions to
compute stuff or I like confused I did
not know about that okay I think and I
don't people do not take leave what's
actually the right thing to do it's not
even clear to what to really apply
machine learning but in general I'm
interested in after version 1 of this is
released doing something to natively do
electronic structure just simple
hartree-fock yes I know he told us all
right right it's okay so question um DFT
that was so fancy back thirty years ago
it still it I mean I mean the serum that
has a one-to-one map it we in the ground
state and the density is still a
collectively what about pedagogical
methods such as focal I am unfamiliar
yes down the road we may not have this
for this okay can somebody add
stereocenters to the spellchecker should
I send that an awesome email okay okay
okay quite beautiful these Feldon know
you haven't got these yet right
okay so I have a a a couple of questions
on the atom list page I believe that's
where they are about property naming
conventions okay hold on second we've
still got this unique result goodness
okay so is there are mines at most and
mappings multiple mappings are the same
set of atoms so is there something that
we have in string matching which is that
same kind of issue multiple matches that
that's something that could happen in
many functions right because if you have
a pattern you know how do we specify
that how do we say that like string
match
well there's string cases senator you
can allow overlaps is that what you're
talking about that's what I'm talking
about I think um
is it cold allow overlaps its overlaps
goes to all yeah is that relevant for
this oh yes it would be it would be it
isn't quite
but it's a dear friend well what exactly
is this multiple matches to the same set
of atoms that sounds like an overlap
right and if it were by default false
the user could turn into like on there's
an example in there where in the find
molecule substructure page where well
right so that is for that one if you use
the unique result goes to all our goes
to false option you would receive all of
the isomorphisms between the benzene and
the ring so let's just try this for one
second so I understand what you're
talking about
um okay so we've got a molecule here
that's just just because it's such fun
to do this let's just try this oh there
we go
cool molecule okay how correct is this
likely to be I mean if we did x-ray
crystallography on this would this be
basically the right shape no it's a good
shape for a molecule in isolation I see
any general in a in a in solution that
thing is gonna be floppy and I don't
think the the crystal structure is all
that well-defined I mean something like
that is gonna be very foggy including my
experience with floppiness and molecules
is mostly based on you know tayos you
know chemists chemicals app where you
could sort of a pad move the atoms
around and yeah I mean I one get some
intuition that this is somewhat floppy
are we gonna have a way to figure that
out because we should know that stuff
right so I should be rotatable so I
don't that should be an option you
should be able in the highlighting to
say highlight rotatable bonds yeah and
it would be great to put a slider on
them as well next version to do what I
mean so what Te'o had was multi-touch
where you can touch on a on an iPad for
example you can touch any of the atoms
and give them a force
this would be different you you would
basically put a dial on a rotatable bond
and the the smaller end of it would
rotate in space as you turn the dial I'm
not sure that's the right I mean look
that the main question is in Boise yeah
go ahead
then maybe a version of the new random
instant with the temperature parameter
could do it yes that would be beautiful
then you would you know kind of then you
have natural at least scale at your ends
right yes that's another application you
know that's another thing like simulated
annealing right but I mean so what it
would be as random instance of molecule
comet temperature you know 200 Kelvin or
something then they make to India and
then you see yeah it can bend and how
much it's nice right but but for
molecular design purposes you're trying
to fit something inside of a site you
know an active site or receptor pocket
you want to be able to modify manually
the specific conformation to see how
well it fits or not yeah that seems like
something you should take it out into a
3d you know into unity or something like
that and you know move it around yeah
something like that so yeah because
you're going to be able to select pieces
and rotate and so on yes amazing if we
could hook molecule molecule modify up
to to unity link we have unity link we
have molecule modify oh I wouldn't be
able to come up I know I don't see a
reason I just think it would be fine
that's all yes I agree I mean the next
thing is Mike your scale videogames
little pac-man molecules running around
eating each other for example you know
just people with getting intuition about
what happens on a molecular scale um
futures chemistry education yes yeah I
think nobody really has that well only
people have been in the biz for a long
time have that intuition recently all
right so now that is a benzene you're
telling me right and you want that to be
the second argument
the pattern okay and so that should just
give you what what is the batter I'm
sorry those patterns are in smarts is
that right
yes why don't we say that um symbolic
pattern well as looking originally had
them being two separate heads one with
all ICO smarts is that right yes yep
okay so this the default is all or not
know the default is is one just because
you might give it some highly symmetric
molecule in some tiny pattern and it
would combinatoric Li explode okay so
here your wacky unique whatever it is
what is it unique unique results laughs
goes to false right oh no you want true
no you you want false it's by default
true because those are all trivial
basically it's okay so let me understand
all these overlaps are they something
different
their overlaps yeah so if I if I say
Keys slash at that what I'm gonna see is
that there are many so if I do an array
plot for example that I'm going to see
there are many I don't mean to do an
array plot those are stupid thing to do
i what I want to do as a sparse I want
to do a list what do I want to do I want
to just find out how many copies there
are is that going to do anything useful
I think so yeah so that's showing me
that many of these things but the you
and tell you of thought I think a more
useful one to about overlaps would be
looking at benzenes inside of a
naphthalene or anthracene molecule and
that would show the overlaps there are
different ways asking on our live stream
by the way can we take smile strings and
and return when I you pack name you know
the answer is yes in fact we can do that
in fact we should put that on this page
right how we do that with an interpreter
that's how we would do that in a very
limited sense brain if they if they're
in our knowledge base we can get the
name we don't have to I couldn't to to
boot do it going the other way from a
name to oh I see name to structure we
have what should we list that on this
page so we never fully settled on what
the design would be if it were an
interpreter or a was a chemical identify
so yeah now molecule simply just takes
the smiles and will create a structure
or it takes the name and will create a
structure okay by the way one thing that
I found fun to do and maybe you guys can
tell me a better way to do this but but
um this was just I was trying to demo
this thing and I was some
um this was kind of a fun thing to do
um I mean is that is there a better way
to do this
those will all be linear long I know
that so how do I make how do I in an
easy way
make a nonlinear molecule without having
to worry about some matching brands
no smiles well enough tonight so you
could random so you would need to
randomly insert the number one at two
positions in the resulting string and
that would create a loop okay yes I
think that or as you said we're matching
parens but that almost sounds like you
want to do something that's some kind of
depth-first algorithm like right yeah
okay so if I just if I just edit this
thing and I stick a 1 in there and a 1
in there and then I say molecule um of
that and I like you
molecule plot 3d oh it's taking it some
time
improper valence state okay well so much
for that I'm positioned for Y so move
that although that it's the oxygen the
carbon or nitrogen yep yeah there you go
okay that's very jolly yeah it probably
Keatley at a metal very nicely actually
yeah I could be right there yeah
yeah all those oxygens the nitrogen is
pointing there lone pairs at it um
alright we really need to get that thing
where we can get individual like metal
atoms and things hanging out properly
yep
it's an ER list okay all right back back
to this unique thing so is overlaps a
valid thing to use here I think it
sounds like it is overlaps ro true or
false yeah yep so sure
is it does it rise to the level I don't
think it rises to the level of
mentioning on the guide page so just go
ahead and put it in and they and they
know I think it's not most people aren't
gonna just want to use the default
setting for it okay so the questions
from our live stream will be will to
plot this region unpaired electron spins
in radicals or the changes in orbitals
and charge distribution as the reaction
progresses that is very challenging
isn't it yes especially the ladder that
modeling a chemical reaction is you know
people have been trying to do that for
eons and my understanding is only in
simple cases can that be done is that
true yeah yeah it all depends on on the
level of theory you're willing to use
and how much CPU power you've got right
somebody's asking how will out plots
compare to PI mole I think they're
pretty good um I assume we've done
detailed comparison
- stuff like that so I mainly look at
Avogadro night primal but I will yeah
questions about other planned links to
Gaussian gammas etc James earlier
already yeah so probably not Avogadro I
mean that's that would be doing pretty
much the same thing that we're doing but
the Gaussian in games is there a good
transfer format how do you transfer the
data is it in mole files running or what
so reading Gaussian output files is a
sport in and of itself but writing
writing them also write write it so I so
as far as Gaussian output files I'm
interested in looking at open babble and
you doing something to which already has
a pretty good method for importing
Gaussian output files and that kind of
thing so that I mean that is the
direction that I'm most interested in
because that's my background the
question any plans for plotting zero
flux surfaces which I don't know what
they are neither do i okay
I have zero flexor or isosurfaces I
thought I understand electronic
isosurfaces yeah or nodal planes um
suggestion on the live stream to have a
random molecule function we've played
with that a little bit it's a it's
challenging to get something that comes
up realistic right and what would the so
what would the design be would so I
think of it as random molecules C 12 H
17 but Bob thought of it as random
molecule you know
there's a random those are random named
molecules right well that's just
selecting from the collection we have
done those are named molecules why did
that not work have we been through this
before right right because I have not
had a chance I'd like to be able to do
something for random molecules it's like
random graph some distribution why is
that useful I mean is it useful for
basically you know drug discovery ish
type things or is that kind of
ridiculous you know it's useful for that
so what so what you want to be able to
do is like take what did I just do oh
just take like a piece of a molecule and
randomize a piece is that the idea
that's another thing that can be done
I've done that some of that stuff in the
past with genetic programming methods
okay so these we can get except for the
ones that have a random salts and so on
well there it's the poly that we have
several oh we have it's a polymer we do
have that these ideas about how to do
polymers and proteins and things right
we we haven't given a lot of effort
we've talked about it but we've decided
to put those off until a later time okay
yeah I think we speak about two
different things
so we have something kind of for a mark
or description of them not a kind of
atomic level so somebody on the live
stream is saying hi mold can do it I
don't know what it is maybe random
molecule um well anyway okay it looks
great so I will push back these changes
I any other design issues that we need
to talk about let's see yeah so when we
might we meet again but and if it's not
gonna be in the next couple of days I
question about property names and oh god
for which function atom list
so it's a quick question are we do we
absolutely hate property names that end
in the word queue I like it because I
think what we have good more open to it
lately yeah I feel so I like unsaturated
atom q2 tell me whether it's whether
whether the atom is unsaturated or not I
think it's okay okay it's okay I mean I
think we're I agree that it's pretty
clear what they mean and I don't really
see a problem okay all right well thanks
everybody and thanks for the comments on
the live stream for those interested
there will be one more live stream
tonight I believe about geo
functionality in about two hours
alright see you soon thank you